شو احلامك احلامي انه الاحتلال الصون يطلع
من ارضنا حلمي نرجع على البيت انه تتحرر
غزه من الحرب تاخذ المسجد
[موسيقى]
الاقصى كان نفسي انجح واجيب مجموع عالي
ومعدل عالي وافرح وافرح اهلي وادخل
الجامعه وادرس واسير ولكن بطل في طموح بطل
كل كل شي تكسر كل شي انا كان حلمي اني
اصير بروفسوره وكنت في المدرسه وطموحي بس
كل شي تهدم المدرسه تحطمت وكل شي تحطم كل
شي الحين انا صار حلمي الحين في الوقت
الحالي انه انا اصلا اقعد فقط في مكان امن
فقط هي الح انا حلمي
بحلمه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا انا اسمي لما ابو جاموس عمري تسع
سنوات انا انا اصغر صحفيه في قطاع غزه
وانا بدي احكي لكم كيف يومي في قطاع غزه
اول ما نصحى من نصحى على صوت الزنانات
والانفجارات والطاغوت الاشتباكات كمان
بيقربوا علينا ونحن بنخاف بروح عند ماما
بضل ن جنبها حواليها عشان ما نخاف قبل
الحرب كان موجود كل شيء كان في خضروات وكل
شيء كان فيه يما بدات الحرب انقطع كل شيء
علينا ما فيش اكل فش شرب غير كميات قليله
وغالي سعرها تصف طوابير عشان تلاقي الميه
وتشرب غيرما تكون عندهم الميه بتكون
الصالحه غر يشربوه غصب عنهم عشان فيش مياه
غر ما يصفوا طوابير بحب اكثر شيء اكمل
دراستي واكون صحفيه زي كل الصحفيين
وبحب انه ياما اكبر اكون صحفيه كبيره زي
زي خالته هبه المراسله وعم وائل
الدحدوح وخالته بان وحاتم الرواغ انا بحب
اوصل الاوضاع على على اطفال غزه عشان
يوقفوا الحرب عليهم ويوقفوا القصف ويوقفوا
كل شي عليهم طيب انت ما بتخافي يصيرلك شي
في بهله الصحافه لا بخاف بس بحب انه اكون
صحفيه زي كل صحفيه احنا بنتمنى العالم
توقف الحرب علينا هم زي ما هم شايفين
المجازي اللي بيعملوها فينا هم ما بحسو
فينا هم ليش ليش بدهم يوقفوا عنا الحرب
نحنا بدنا توقف الحرب عشان نرجع على
بيوتنا وعلى المدارس ونلعب بالشارع زي ما
كنا زمان كانت معكم لما ابو جاموس من قطاع
غزه
الجزيره
ت